[Música]
en esta sección directo a vamos directos
hasta la frontera entre México y Estados
Unidos concretamente a Ciudad Juárez
allí hay cierta tranquilidad pese al
caos que se esperaba una vez acabara a
la medianoche de este jueves el título
42 la ley promulgada por Donald Trump
que permitía la expulsión inmediata de
inmigrantes alegando motivos de salud
pública Por ese motivo cientos de
migrantes se unieron en los últimos días
en Ciudad Juárez a los que ya esperaban
allí a cruzar hacia Estados Unidos antes
de que este viernes entraran en vigor
las nuevas y también restrictivas normas
para hablar sobre ello conectamos con
nuestro enviado especial Andrés Suárez
Jaramillo Andrés cómo transcurrió Este
primer día de haberse finalizado el
título 42 Y qué hubo de particular en la
frontera
Hola Rodrigo pues ha transcurrido muy
tranquilamente desde la medianoche del
jueves a este viernes y a lo largo del
día ha transcurrido todo en calma en
calma en normalidad tanto en el puente
internacional paso del Norte Como en las
diferentes puertas a lo largo de todo el
muro metálico que separa este estado de
Chihuahua con el de Texas los últimos
migrantes que lograron cruzar lo
hicieron por cuenta de la puerta 42 eso
fue durante la noche y durante la
madrugada en varios autobuses lograron
pasar hasta el paso Texas pero ya hoy no
se registraba mayor movimiento apenas
una veintena de colombianos que
intentaron cruzar entregarse a las
autoridades Ellos están pidiendo que por
favor los cobije el título 42 y no el
título 8 porque alegan de que cruzaron
durante antes de la medianoche pero por
lo pronto se registra mucha normalidad
tranquilidad y no se ha cumplido aquello
de que iban a haber Ríos iban a ver
avalanchas de migrantes
nos estabas hablando del título 8 es la
antigua política fronteriza que estaba
ya antes de la pandemia con esta entrada
En vigor qué registros se ha tenido
durante el primer día sobre migrantes
procesados
bueno donde sí ha habido una gran
cantidad de migrantes procesados en es
en la región del Valle del Río Grande
allí la jefa de la patrulla fronteriza
Gloria Chávez hoy de una rueda de prensa
en la que dijo que hubo 1800
aprehensiones Y que todos ellos van a
ser procesados por el título 8 pero hay
una particularidad Y es que podrán ser
deportados a México y no a sus países de
origen como lo estipula la normativa
pero sí es como un llamado de atención a
todos aquellos migrantes que quieran
cruzar la frontera sin desconocer sin
conocer Este título aquí particularmente
en lo que es el Paso Texas que es la
ciudad que colinda con Ciudad Juárez no
ha habido mayor movimiento apenas se han
registrado unos 300 migrantes que han
intentado cruzar pero que no han podido
hacerlo porque Definitivamente hay mucha
seguridad se han alargado diferentes
barreras de alambres de Púas que
nosotros mismos hemos podido ver y
además a pesar de que se quieren
entregar los migrantes pues no han
podido hacerlo solo como una anécdota
encontramos a un grupo de venezolanos
que querían cruzar hoy no importase cómo
les explicamos les preguntamos si sabían
del título 8 dijeron que no tenían
absolutamente ningún conocimiento les
explicamos De qué se trataba y dijeron
pues este es nuestro destino pase pase
lo que pase con nosotros lo aceptaremos